[Musique]
on
où j'ai pris la fuite
c'était poisson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
veut je vais tout vous ne maintenant
c'est ma gueule dans mon bureau depuis
bon les amis faut qu'on se pose de
minutes on parle lors plus il ya un
nouveau phénomène là qu'un train
d'arriver qu'ici c'est passé qu'est ce
que je loupais genre yeux il n'y a pas
là il n'y a pas une genre c'est à dire
que pour cette situation il n'ya pas
avec un genre
exemple peut m'en offusque garde on peut
me refuser sera fait terrain parfois
passer à un seul genre quand on creuse
que tu le croises le patin il est mignon
c'est chiant ou alors quand ton prof de
maths see that expliquer ce que c'est
que la racine carrée duit
actuelle à l'école comme ça en fait
genre bon sur ce je vous laisse bon
dimanche et n'oubliez pas les appareils
comme ça en fait je n'y a pas inventé
des expressions comme ça y'a
i'm so happy
il fait 22 degrés dans ma maison et shem
web de fautes
je mange mon programme
sur la châsse
une folie
[Musique]